our speaker today is the editor-in-chief
in The Daily wire we all love him
obviously from the ben shapiro show the
top conservative podcasts in the nation
he was 17 when he became a syndicated
you know show host the youngest in
America's history he's the author of
seven books several of them have ended
up on the New York Times bestseller list
honestly he earned his BA in political
science at UCLA graduated from Harvard
Law alright and what I appreciate about
him is that we might not share the same
faith I mean he is a devout Jewish
friend and we are Christians but this
morning we talked so much about what we
have in common and so much about our
desire to see the sanctity of life be
protected in the life of a baby in a
womb we talked a lot about our beliefs
in wanting to see wanting to see this
place return and and he really is I
think a partner with us not just the
guest who's gonna find a lot in common
with us but a partner with us and in
ways that we're excited about unrolling
in the next few years to you but I know
you're excited I'm gonna get out of the
way come on let's put our hands together
for the one the only everybody
well thank you so much
[Applause]
it really is a pleasure and an honor to
be here today at Liberty University I'd
like to give a special thanks to Fred
Allen and young America's Foundation for
making this event possible
obviously sponsoring these sorts of
events makes it possible for me to bring
good news and good words to I think a
lot of folks around the country here I
think they need it less than maybe some
of the other places that I speak before
I begin I wanted to take just a moment
so we can silently pray together for
Alfie Evans if you don't know the story
of Alfie Evans Alfie Evans is a
two-year-old child in Britain who has a
degenerative brain condition and the
government of Britain is now declaring
that his parents cannot leave the
country without the evans to seek
experimental treatment he has to stay in
a hospital and die at the hand of the
state so before we go any further I'd
like to just take about five seconds
here ten seconds and just pray silently
fora for Alfie and his family who are I
think doing God's work and standing up
for the value of life thank you I
appreciate it
well I've long believed that the future
of our nation is inextricably
intertwined with the future of
judeo-christian value system and I know
of very few places in the United States
that are more valuable to that future
than right here at Liberty University
I'm just blown away by you guys
America was built on a fundamental idea
an idea that was the product of nearly
3,000 years of philosophical evolution
that idea planted at Sinai watered in
the Galilee pruned through the thought
of Athens and strengthened by the push
and pull of reason and revelation for
centuries was embedded by our founders
in the Declaration of Independence and
the Constitution of the United States
that principle is simple that human
beings are made in the image of God that
we are therefore beneficiaries of the
inalienable god-given rights that
government was created in order to
protect those rights not invade them and
that we must use our freedom to preserve
reach to pursue virtue God said to
Pharaoh let my people go so that they
may worship me hey the United States
echoed that message from it's very
inception George Washington stated in
his first inaugural address quote since
there exists in the economy and course
of nature an indissoluble union between
virtue and happiness between duty and
advantage the propitious smiles of
heaven can never be expected on a nation
that disregards the eternal Rules of
Order and right which heaven itself has
ordained the very basis of our politics
then lies in the recognition that rights
without virtues lead to chaos and that
virtues without Rights lead to tyranny
only by balancing public rights with
private virtues can we truly uphold
freedom and pursue happiness one half of
the equation though seems to have gone
awry in modern America we've been taught
that our rights are paramount which is
fine but we have also been taught that
we have no duty to be virtuous in fact
anyone who says that we have a duty to
be virtuous is harming you micro
aggressing you at most centrically
mansplaining to you in cisgender fashion
how can anyone expect us to be virtue
the argument goes when the system itself
is so deeply flawed how can we blame
people for being immoral when the system
is biased in favor of a few white rich
men at the top first we have to fix the
system then human beings themselves will
change virtue will become natural wall
just magically become wonderful great
people all we have to do to make this
magical thing happen is hand over all
our freedoms to a centralized government
and that government will then provide us
new rights you know better than the old
god-given ones instead of the rights of
free speech the government will provide
us a right not to be a
our feelings will be protected instead
of a right to life the government will
provide us the right to kill unborn
babies instead of a right to create and
keep the wages of our labor the
government will provide us a nice
comfortable social safety net without us
actually having to do the work then
after all that's done human beings will
magically become better will become good
if all this happens this is the
philosophy of collectivism the
philosophy that says that human beings
suffer because the judeo-christian
system expects too much of us
individually judeo-christian philosophy
expects us to struggle to strive
judeo-christian philosophy demands that
we do our best and that we act
virtuously on the individual level so we
can feel secure without invading each
other's rights the judeo-christian
tradition says that with freedom comes
responsibility collectivist philosophy
however thinks differently they expect
us to give our individual striving up no
more striving no more struggle all we
have to do is trade our individual
responsibility for the comfort of
collective power collectivist philosophy
points out that individual virtue isn't
natural it is a struggle and we can
avoid that struggle by handing over all
power to a nanny state
judeo-christianity says you're free and
therefore you must give collectivist
philosophy says your unfree and thus the
state must take on your behalf it's this
philosophy of collectivism against which
Moses and Jesus and George Washington
and Thomas Jefferson and James Madison
fought it is this philosophy that
Americans have fought and bled and died
to extend to more and more people over
time Abraham Lincoln saw black slaves as
human beings and hundreds of thousands
of Americans died to extend the American
covenant to them American soldiers left
their corpses on the beaches of Normandy
to extend that promise to subject
people's Martin Luther King jr. was
assassinated fighting to extend the
American promise to black Americans
Ronald Reagan spent his years fighting
to spread the light of Americanism
beyond the Berlin Wall and today
Americans liberate Muslims in the Middle
East from the heavy hand of collectivist
Islamism Americans protect South Koreans
and Taiwanese free people from the
burden of North Korean and Chinese
communism Americans stand ready to
thwart the threat of collectivist
tyranny across the globe but there is a
threat to founding philosophy growing
right here at home it's growing because
too many Americans believe that virtue
is less important than
to signaling hey too many Americans
believe that freedom is actually a
burden too many Americans believe that
they know what's best for other
Americans even when they personally
abandon virtue so the question becomes
how exactly do we go about restoring the
judeo-christian tradition upon which the
nation was built how exactly do we bring
back the philosophy of the founders and
restore their promise well to do that we
have to go back to basics we actually
have to talk about morality and politics
not just efficiency not just why our
ideas were but morality what is good and
what is bad what is right what is wrong
what is true and what is evil now
advocates for personal philosophy if our
founding philosophy you know these
personal freedoms individual
responsibility we make a pretty big
mistake when we talk about that
philosophy because we do spend a lot of
time talking about how effective it is
we point out that free markets have led
to the greatest reduction in poverty in
world history in 1981 40 4.3 percent of
the global population lived on less than
a buck 90 a day in 2015 the global
extreme poverty rate dipped below 10% we
on the right like to point out that a
philosophy of individualism has led to
massive increases in living standards
within the United States
and also around the world and we point
out the collectivist countries tend to
stagnate but we don't point to often two
underlying values see here's the thing
we have to acknowledge there is a draw
to collectivism there is a draw to
leftism the draw is pretty simple
collectivism promises solutions to
cosmic and Justices when collectivist
stands up here and invoke the least
specific I mean like here on this stage
and invoke the least specific verses of
the Bible to justify government
redistribution ISM and crackdowns on
religious practice because of fairness
they are making a moral appeal when
Bernie Sanders stands up here and tells
you that the top 1% of the 1% Oh 90
percent of all the wealth
when he says that America is not a just
society in line with a context-free
verse from a book he's never read by
Amos and then suggest that if you give
him more power he will rectify that
unfairness that is immoral appeal it is
not it is not an argument about
efficiency it's a bad moral appeal of
course inequality doesn't necessarily
mean unfairness but it is a moral appeal
and that moral appeal unfortunately for
as many people is effective it's
effective because it goes to our hearts
not to our heads it reminds us of
fundamental values even if it's skewing
those fundamental values conservatives
tend to talk about what works people on
the Left tend to talk about what's fair
but values are not a left-wing monopoly
in fact the fundamental values of
Western civilization run a hell of a lot
deeper than the shallow values of the
collectivists the values that resonate
most with human beings are eternal not
changeable and not relativistic they are
universal they are not groups specific
and most of all they apply to individual
human beings not group labels if those
values were first embedded clearly and
concisely in the ten commandments if we
return to those values will be a
virtuous citizen rate deserving of our
Liberty and if we turn away from those
values well then we'll return to the
horror of collectivism in tyranny so I'm
going to go through the ten commandments
and I want to explain what they say to
today's modern politics what they say to
us in the room and why the Ten
Commandments are so important and why
they are still the basis for our
outreach program on behalf of not only
our God but on behalf of a philosophy
that is the only remaining hope for
Western civilization so the first
commandment is the most controversial
and it's also the simplest I'm the LORD
thy God who brought you out of Egypt out
of the land of bondage now to start off
this is a bizarre commandment because it
doesn't actually command you to do
anything on its face but it does
implicitly command you to do something
remove yourself from the arbitrary
bondage of the state and place yourself
under a higher set of Commandments the
Bible tells us in Genesis that we are
each made in God's image and that means
we have the capacity to choose and the
obligation to choose right over wrong
and life over death responsibility
devolves on us personally because we're
servants of God not servants of the
state across three millennia Jews and
Christians alike have fought for the
common notion that our allegiance to God
outranks our allegiance to the state and
that
you use government to restrict my
communion with godly values I will
resist you in every way possible
today collectivists folks on the left
they tell us that the state can order
you to disobey God in your daily
dealings right they can order the
Christian Baker to cater the same-sex
wedding they can order the Jewish doctor
like my wife to perform abortions right
the first commandment says no you can't
and so does the first amendment which
guarantees freedom of religion for
precisely this reason and it's because
the founders understood the danger of
tyranny and the value of individual
freedom before God they instituted the
second amendment to they recognized that
we have a god-given right to defend
ourselves from tyranny and from terror
[Music]
the second commandment is also
particularly important in today's
society it says thou shalt have no other
gods before me this is particularly
relevant when it comes to the cults of
personality that seems to dominate our
politics we're told on all sides then we
have to trust the people at the top to
solve our problems a little bit of trust
goes a long way every time something
goes wrong in the United States we are
informed that if we just gave the
government more power our problems would
be solved like ancient pagans if we
sacrifice a bowl on top of a mountain
the Health and Human Services Department
will ensure nobody dies in cancer
this is stupid nonsense Bernie and
Elizabeth Warren worship at the altar of
fairness they proclaim the universe is
cosmically unjust if you just hand over
power to them all of that will be cured
God says nah God says we are not allowed
to trust in Princes and that means that
it is also our job to call out our
leaders when they stray to do otherwise
is to deify human beings it is not our
job to ignore the sins of our leaders by
determining that they are in fact King
David selected by God to fulfill his
will it is our job to be Nathan the
Prophet declaring wrongs when we see
them in service to God
[Music]
if our leaders sinned we are bound to
say why did you despise the word of the
Lord by doing what is evil in his eyes
and our leaders must repent to merit
God's love just as we must constantly
repent before him power doesn't exempt
sin and if it did our leaders would be
gods and we would be their subjects the
third commandment says that we must not
take God's name in vain
this doesn't merely mean that we
shouldn't shout God bleep it God can
handle a little potty mouth it does mean
that we can't twist God's words to
justify our own political agendas
[Music]
Christian's cannot justify abortion by
misquoting Matthew 7:12 and talking
about the golden rule if they do they
are putting their own words in God's
mouth we can't use we cannot use
Deuteronomy 16 20 to justify a
government cracking down on religious
people to promote same-sex marriage
while deliberately ignoring the words of
Leviticus okay and we cannot justify
forcible redistribution of wealth by
citing matthew on the least of these
while ignoring the words of leviticus 19
15 in which god enjoins us not to
pervert justice on behalf of the poor or
the wealthy selectively citing the bible
while ignoring all the inconvenient
parts that makes you a Bible abuser and
it makes you dishonest as well the
fourth commandment says then we must
remember the Sabbath and keep it holy
one of the weirdest elements of
collectivism is that it says we all owe
something to the collective and yet
weirdly collectivist seems to give a lot
less to charity New York Mayor Bill
DeBlasio routinely rips into the greedy
rich the guy gave a grand total of 350
bucks to charity last year on an
adjusted gross income of two hundred
twenty three thousand four hundred forty
nine dollars by the way he paid the guy
who for various taxes five hundred bucks
when you see income as the state's
responsibility rather than a gift from
God it alleviates the responsibility of
actually having to pass that gift on to
those who are less fortunate
instead you can demand that the
government play God and grab other
people's cash the commandment to honor
the Sabbath also reminds us that our
time doesn't actually belong to the
state it belongs to us every seven days
we say no more tyrannies say that our
labor is not our own we owe it to the
collective our time is in her own our
income isn't our own our labor isn't our
own work harder because the state is
your Creator remember that our time is a
gift from God
that's the first step toward fighting
tyranny the fifth commandment says that
we have to honor our parents obviously
this calls a lot of folks on the left
really galls them see collectivists see
the state as the source of our morals
and our families obstacles standing
between individuals and their master
that's exactly what's happening with
Alfie Evans where bureaucrats are
standing between parents and their child
saying that they know best that a child
has to die because they know better than
the parents do collectivist they there's
a reason that
Karl Marx abhorred the traditional
family hey let's just say that he sought
as a capitalist institution based on
capital and on private gain he openly
called for abolition of the family
there's a reason Stalin trained Soviet
youth to become pioneers that's what he
called them emissaries of the state
we're told that the highest good
involves ratting out your own family
members at 1 1932 Soviet trial a father
actually cried out to his son it's me
your father and the son replied yes he
used to be my father but I no longer
consider him my father I'm not acting as
a son but as a pioneer Stalin used to go
around
Soviet Russia talking about this story
and using it as an example of good
behavior
hey breaking down the family is a
precondition to building up the state
and furthermore respecting your parents
means you actually have to respect their
belief systems you know the ones that
have been passed down generation after
generation the ones that your
grandparents spill blood for GK
Chesterton wrote in 1929 the more modern
type of reformer goes gaily up to a
fence and says I don't see the use of
this let us clear it away the more
religious type of reformer would do well
to answer quote if you don't see the use
of it I certainly won't let you clear it
away go away and think then when you can
tell me come back and tell me that you
do see the use of it then I may allow
you to destroy it the founders
understood the value of the past the
authors of the French Revolution didn't
this is why Edmund Burke condemned the
French Revolution he saw the
revolutionaries as stripping away fences
that were built over thousands of years
of human thought he said their liberty
is not liberal their scientists
presumptuous ignorance their humanity is
savage and brutal and Edmund Burke was
right our parents may be wrong from time
to time but to presume as so many on the
left do that we can ignore the lessons
of the past to discard our parents build
the worlds in new each generation that
consigns thousands if not millions to
flames the sixth commandment is pretty
simple and we should all be able to
agree on that secular religious alike
now shall not murder unfortunately as we
are currently seeing in Britain this is
not the case collectivists routinely
dismissed the value of human life this
by the way is the difference between
social justice and individual justice
individual justice demands that you have
to be held responsible for the stuff you
do for your own crimes social justice
says that your life on its own is of
little consequence if a few eggs must be
broken to make an omelet then that's the
way it works to ask for raw evidence of
wrongdoing becomes of secondary concern
the only thing that matters is the end
goal when we use people as mean
rather than ends murder becomes possible
and by the way it's actually kind of
easy to use human beings as means rather
than ends there's a famous study that
was done at Yale University by Stanley
Milgram in 1961 and here's how it works
he chose pairs of participants one would
randomly be chosen to become a learner
and the other randomly chosen become a
teacher accepted selection was not
random the drawing was rigged so the
volunteers would become teachers and the
learners were actually working for the
experimenter there working for Milgram
so the learners were taken into a
separate room and they were hooked up to
electrodes that were supposedly buzzing
with electricity teachers the volunteers
in this program were brought into a
separate room containing a switch they
could shift the electric level from 15
volts all the way up to 450 volts
teachers these volunteers were then
informed by the researchers that it was
their job to shock learners for making
errors in a war game the researchers
would remain in the world in the room
and they would push the teachers to
shock the learners telling them to
continue according to Milgram
experiments 2 in 3 teachers shocked the
learners all the way up to 450 volts
even as the actors begged for mercy
every one of the teachers shocked the
learners up to 300 volts
Milgram concluded quote stark Authority
was pitted against the subjects
strongest moral imperatives against
hurting others and with the subjects
peers ringing with the screams of the
victims authority one more often than
not hey people are not averse to murder
unless they are taught that they are
personally responsible for the actions
they take nowhere is this truer than in
the case of abortion no we're a society
we have taught individual human beings
around the United States and around the
world they are not responsible for their
actions that's how you get a piece in
The Washington Post by Ruth Marcus
championing the killing of unborn
children with Down syndrome Shep she
wrote this quote I'm gonna be blunt here
this was not the child I wanted you can
call me selfish or worse but I am in
good company it takes generations of
inculcation advice in order to believe
such idiocy she is wrong
Ruth Marcus is wrong she is not in good
company she is in quite evil company but
human beings have always provided each
other company when pursuing evil without
being taught an individual system of
virtue are you are responsible for the
actions that you take the seventh the
seventh commandment is not to commit
adultery again you would think that this
one would be obvious right
it isn't unfortunately this commandment
assumes the value of individual human
beings it assumes that you have the
individual capacity to control your own
nature collectivists reject both of
these assumptions wholesale there's a
reason that Marx believed in what he
called the community of women in that
widespread promiscuity the idea that one
man and one woman must sublimate their
desires in order to promise each other
their trust and love it stands in stark
contrast to the ownership of the
collective family formation is the
single greatest threat to the
substitution of leftist values for
judeo-christian ones because it assumes
that you personally are capable of
overcoming your own nature and because
the creation of children changes your
life it means that you are now
responsible for someone else your
highest priority is protection of your
family rather than serving the
collective I have two kids now they made
me a better human being kids make you a
better human being if you allow them to
and being married to one person for the
rest of your life makes you a better
human being as well
[Music]
furthermore the commandment not to
commit adultery actually places pleasure
below commitment on the scale of
priorities and this annoys a lot of
people this runs counter to the
comforting promises of the collectivist
they say that you should trade away your
rights in order that you have this soft
subpoena and cocoon of security the
promise of zero consequences for your
action give control to the collective
you won't have to control yourself if
you just give control to the collective
over your entire life they will give you
free condoms they will pay for your
abortion all the rest but the
judeo-christian ethic says to control
yourself and then in doing so you become
better and freer and a better servant of
the Lord who made you the eighth
commandment is similarly simple and
should be similarly non-controversial
unfortunately it's not thou shalt not
steal individualism relies on our
respect for one another's rights the
Bible explicitly forbids the notion of
social justice as a rationale for theft
the New Testament says in second
Thessalonians quote the one who is
unwilling to work shall not eat charity
is mandated by judeo-christian religion
theft is forbidden and legalized theft
is still theft
if two of us are in a room with Bill
Gates and we vote to take Bill Gates as
money we are still thieves is a
violation of the eighth commandment just
because that's a democracy doesn't mean
it's not theft corporate welfare is
theft as well when big companies Commons
you're our politics to suck subsidies
from other citizens that is theft to
death isn't just you picking somebody
else's pocket it's you getting together
with your friends and deciding to create
laws that allow you to pick somebody
else's pocket the ninth commandment is
not to bear false witness against your
neighbor perhaps this one is the most
commonly violated commandment of our
time the willingness to suggest that our
neighbors are nasty people bad
characters for the sake of elevating
particular collective ideologies take
for example the issue of gun control now
you can be for more gun control you can
be against more gun control but folks on
the left constantly make the case that
if you oppose their agenda it's because
you don't care enough about dead kids
that you're simply willing to watch them
die for a buck oh five from the National
Rifle Association okay that's not only a
lie it is bearing false witness because
there is no evidence for this
proposition but for a lot of folks on
the Left everyone is either a tool or an
obstacle to utopia and so lying about
your political enemies is simply a great
way to achieve your objective these
character attacks have become
commonplace in our politics the idea
that if you disagree with somebody it's
because they're a bad person not because
you disagree about the underlying values
the underlying principles or agree about
those values and principles but disagree
about the politics themselves instead
everything has become about ripping
people down on a personal level
disagreement becomes a character assault
as long as that lasts we can't have a
free republic finally
finally the tenth commandment you shall
not cover your neighbor's ass
sorry Bill Clinton individualism
individualism is based on the
possibilities inherent within human
beings you're capable of a lot and you
must be encouraged to take advantage of
those possibilities you're not a victim
you're not a victim okay you can achieve
what your neighbor has achieved jealousy
is forbidden by the Bible and if you
can't that gives you no right to believe
that your neighbors property belongs to
you in Judaism this commandment not to
not to covet your neighbor's property
has been interpreted for thousands of
years to mean that you can covet a Tesla
like your neighbors Tesla but you can't
covet your neighbors Tesla which
actually makes perfect sense a free
system offers you the opportunity to
make something of yourself
it offers you the opportunity to do
better it doesn't offer you the ability
to Balam off of somebody else's
achievements collectivism rejects this
and hopes to end jealousy by narrowing
the scope of human potential for you to
redistribute all the property no one
gets the Tesla and maybe jealousy will
go away
that's not how human beings operate it's
a rejection of God and it's a rejection
of the creative power of man God
implanted into all of us
so here's why all of this matters here
who I went through all 10 commandments
hey America is struggling right now in a
lot of ways but the biggest struggle we
are having the most difficult struggle
we are having is the struggle for our
national soul
we're so angry at each other right now
right the anger is palpable when you
going to talk to members your own family
about politics there's no way to have a
good discussion without it's involving
into people yelling at each other well
why are people so angry right now we're
so angry because our common vision has
been destroyed we used to believe in the
founding vision supported by the
framework of personal virtue called from
judeo-christian morality the government
was there to protect us from hurting
each other and judeo-christian morality
was there to inculcate virtue in us so
that government didn't have to step in
hey we used to see each other as
brothers and sisters as friends and
family not the 1% versus the 99% or the
privilege versus the victims we were not
enemies we were a community forged in
fire tethered together by a set of
values stretching all the way back to
the Garden of Eden but no longer
somewhere along the way we came to
believe that we stood above the
tradition that bore us and we were
better than the philosophical system of
the founders we began to think we were
better than God we began to score in our
past we began to think we could remake
the world tearing down fences without
considering why those fences were there
in the first place we were wrong
they were it is our job to repair those
fences not to tear them down to repair
them to learn about them to realize why
we were there only then can we change
the placement of those fences
it is our job to learn as you're doing
here at Liberty about what made our
civilization great and what can make our
civilization great still it is our job
to reconnect with both the Word of God
and with the philosophy of individual
liberty that sprang from that same Word
of God if we do all of that if we do all
of that then we will truly be deserving
of God's blessing and Fitz proclaim
Liberty throughout all the land unto all
the inhabitants thereof thank you so
much
you